i made myself uh
a promise many years ago that i would
not
be a whiner so when something bad
happens to me
of course it's that's a process the
disappointment but then
i try to focus on what did i learn from
this that can make me a better person in
the future
and there's usually something to be
learned when i fail
and i think we should all ask ourselves
what
can we learn from the pandemic about how
we can do better in the future
and you mentioned there's a really good
lesson you know we were not as resilient
as we thought we were and we were not as
prepared
maybe as we wish you were you can even
see very stark contrast around the
planet
south korea right they have over 50
million people
do you know how many deaths they have
from covet last time i checked
no about 500
know why is that well
the short answer is that they had
prepared
they were incredibly quick incredibly
quick to get on it
with very rapid testing and contact
tracing and so on
which is why they never had more cases
than they could contract trace
effectively right they never even had to
have the kind of big lockdowns we had in
the west
but the deeper answer to it's not just
the koreans are just somehow
better people the reason i think they
were better prepared was because they
had already had a pretty bad hit
from the sars pandemic or which never
became a pandemic
something like 17 years ago i think so
it's kind of a fresh memory that you
know we need to be prepared for
pandemics
so they were right and
so maybe this is a lesson here for all
of us to draw
from covid that rather than just wait
for the next pandemic or the next
problem with ai getting out of control
or anything else
maybe we should just actually set aside
a tiny fraction of our gdp
to have people very systematically do
some horizon scanning and say okay
what are the things that could go wrong
and let's duke it out and see which are
the more likely ones and which are the
ones that are actually actionable
and then be prepared
you